This is Quentin, Tennessee Christmas fire 1956
Population 4000
That's the high school basketball team in action against Lake City
They lost
63 to 43 last year they don't had a good football season this year in spite of all the recent couple
The Clinton pep band plays rock around the clock and to all Outward appearances
It's just another night in just another, Tennessee community
but main street has not always been be it there have been mobs in a square before the courthouse and
Wyatt's had to be broken up by the national Guard and a white Baptist Minister was beaten up on Broad Street
The violence in Clinton was news all over America and much of the rest of the world
But this is not a report on the national guard in Clinton
Or the tanks in the street or the tear gas or the burning crosses, but rather an examination after the fact?
filmed in Clinton between December 4 when the reverend Turner was attacked and now
It is an attempt by see it now and the citizens of Clinton
To explore the chain of events and emotions which brought violence and shame and hope to this town
All the persons to be heard during a 60 minute report will be citizens of Clinton
with the exception of Judge Robert L Taylor of Knoxville and John Kasper of Washington
both active participants in the Conflict
of the four thousand people who live in Clinton more than 3,700 are white and
By tradition and custom most of them believe in separate school
In nineteen fifty negro parents backed by the National Association for the advancement of colored people
Brought suit against the Anderson County school system which administers Clinton High school?
Asking that their children be admitted the courier [news] the Clinton weekly spoke for the community and support of segregation
Editor Horace Wells
or any newspaper is inclined to follow the
thinking of the majority of the people in the community and
this community and and I myself have
Favoured segregation all down through the years
[back] when this lawsuit was filed in 1950. We did everything we could to maintain segregation
About trying to provide the negro students with good equal, but separate facilities, and that was why the community [Khaosan]?
That's where the community wanted it
And that was editor of policy this newspaper the federal judge in this section of Tennessee in 1951 and now
Is Robert L Taylor of Knoxville?
the Anderson County
School case was before my court about five years ago
At that time I held that the colored children were not entitled to enter the Clinton High school
Because they were being furnished
equal but separate facilities
At that time the equal, but separate facility [Dr.]. Was the law
the negroes appealed a judge Taylor's decision, and when the supreme court decision of May
1954 Ruled against segregation
judge Taylor's ruling was reversed on
[January] 4 1956 the ordered [Anderson] County to comply
It is hip team of this court that
Desegregation as the high school students in that county should be effective
by developed date and
That a reasonable date
should be fixed as
one not later
than the beginning of the fall term of
the present year [of]
Nineteen hundred and
Fifty-Six
accordingly on August 20 1956
Approximately seven hundred students registered for the fall opening without incident
12 of them were negroes
Judge [Taylor] told them all to obey the law and there seemed to be no questions
Then another voice was heard in Clinton
John Casper an outsider a white supremacist told them that the law need not be obeyed our
Failure today has been failing to attack failing to attack
Failing to attack at every level and continuously
But we in the white Citizens Council say now
Yesterday today and forever as long [as] there is one living white man
the United States the Supreme court is not the law of the land [that] [decision] is not the law now or
Never will be never
John Kasper first came to Clinton on August 25 and threatened to close up the school if desegregation continued
Gasper had certain qualities of leadership and there were those [in] Clinton Willing to be led
103 Days later his Boast was back
An organized campaign of picketing threats dynamiting and rioting that brought Clinton to the Brink of anarchy
Gasper has been arrested plight, but continues to lead the battle against judge Taylor's order
School attendance shrunk by parents fear of violence was at times as low as 260
The pressure mounted on everyone the faculty the parents the student
This is Jerry Shattuck Captain of the football team [and] an all-state guard
talking to reporter Arthur morse in the gymnasium
How did the students react the first day that?
They negros came to class well, [I'd] like to say something about two three weeks preceding the time school starting you know
Our school starts at the 1st of september
And all through the month of august of course we knew we would have negro students in school
That's when we started, but no one said too much about it and no one seemed to
[oppose] to it violently and
Then I believe it was the Saturday before the Monday that school started this casper came into town
And he started calling [people] up and stopping them on streets and trying to form pickets in front of school for Monday morning
And then Monday morning when we did come to school we found that there were oh
15 to 20 people out there with pickets and
The students most of them out [watching] and everything course. You know is something that they'd never seen before and
Then when school started and the nigger students were inside
no one was hostile towards them everyone seemed [offended] all the troubles seemed to be outside the school among the adults and
I'd say six or seven of the students that casper had persuaded to picking
Well of course you know that things kept adding on top of each other and pretty soon
the National Guard came into town and of course things quieted down in a hurry then and then casper left and
For about a month [there] month and a half everything was quiet and then this
the local authorities wanted to try casper owned a
Sedition and inciting a riot. I think it was and then he came into town for that trial [and]
Then after that this intimidation within the school it's happened, just recently started
What sort of intimidation was they go down the halls and maybe push the negro student or I?
Remember they threw some negro students books out into the rain one day
And they poured some ink and eggs down into the negro students locker
And I think they feel booked with a negro student in a study hall
Jerry how do you personally feel about having negro classmates?
well, I
Didn't ask for integration, and I wasn't enthusiastic about getting it
But the supreme court said [that] our high school should be integrated and so I
Felt that I should do all I could to bring this
court order about peacefully I think
Our football coach said put it very well. He said all through your life
You're going to come up against things that you don't like that
he says you're going to have to accept them anyway, and just make the best out of them that you can and
That's why I feel about it too, and I think that that's the way most of the students take
the [twelve] colored students who came down every morning from Bully hill also had a lot to get used to and
then Monday
morning
When we start to school there were only a few people [around] and I thought maybe well
They just here to be curious and they want to see us come in and if they would leave latest
but then on the next day when things when more people came and
A young boy started walking with signs I began to wonder and see well
maybe they're not going to accept this like I thought they were and
on Wednesday morning
I almost cried [for] back home because there were so many people and they look [so]
Mainly they [looked] like they just wanted to grab ass and throw us out. They didn't want us at all
I could just see [their] hate in their heart and
When we got inside the school
Most of the children were very nice to us
And then there was some you could tell [that] they didn't want to scare. They finished a show you in a big [way]
they are precise [Aa] person close [to] get out they all threw paper heads they shoved us and all a
shoot a through trunk at us and
Said all sorts of nasty things and it just made me feel bad
And I couldn't concentrate at all on my lessons
But more than on any other individual the brunt of the pressure was exerted on Principal DJ, Britton, Jr.
Who had fought the original battle for segregation and was now fighting to obey the law of the land?
But Mr.. Britain as principal of Clinton High School
Have you yourself suffered any personal harassment since the situation began?
Umm..[yes], sir
I can frankly say that I've suffered nothing but personal
harassment
And other people to my wife and teachers and students in the school or anybody that took a stand
to obey the law
Not necessarily that they agreed with it, but in any first
for myself the first
day and night my telephone ringing incessantly
I guess my life was threatened 10 or 12 times by anonymous telephone callers who would all hang it up I
I have
Since had my phone number changed four times
To keep from hitting these annoying calls
I received letters
many through the mail
I received two today
[one] of which was an unsigned letter of course which said [that]
They felt that I was a low-down person and used other vile names and felt that
someone should throw acid in my face or in the face of someone in my [family] and
That I wasn't fit to live now
I have had a number [of] those kind of letters now those letters are always anonymous
[they] never put a name on them and
our teachers have been
called
names of all kinds and
they have maked it made a department in the last few [weeks] to
Do anything they could to make [it] [difficult] for the teachers?
How would you characterize the attitude, but most of your pupils in this situation?
They have stood advice
loyally in every test that came up and
We feel that they still do to a large degree. We believe like me we believe that there are maybe 40
students in the school who are creating the trouble that we have at the present [time] and
subject to this
or before this
an organization a youth organization has been organized which was
connected with the white citizens council and as their full backing in I
understand has the same goals and
These people and I have talked to several of them in school are
encouraging other [people] if not doing things themselves
To drive the negroes out of the school now when I talk to Mr. Casper at the beginning
He wanted to know what I was going to do about getting niggers
in those words out of Clinton [High] [School]
And I told him that I had three choices that I could resign my job or I could stay with it and obey the law
or I could do what he said and
That I chose none of those except to abide by the law as it [was] stated
But Mr. [casper] informed me that he was interested in only two things
and those were one to drive the negro students out and
two
To get me out of my job, but here is a matter that is clearly
a decision of the United [States] Supreme court and
[we] do not feel
That if we allow or teach our citizens to Disobey [this] law
That they are learning the right principles assistantship in other words if they can do that
They can violate any other law or any other decision in the country
we've also been working at the problem of trying to get people to understand each other better and
be more tolerant towards each other and
one of the interesting
Developments of this thing is to me has been that I'm now being accused of [being] a Communist [I]
Was born in Tennessee I've lived my life in Tennessee, I attended, Tennessee schools
I attended Merrill College in Tennessee to get my Bachelor's [degree] and
Master's Degree at the University of [Tennessee] and
If there's anything about me that is communistic. I certainly do not know what it is, and it looks to me like
[Rivet] some of the
[Tax]
Methods that are being used against the schools and against myself
[lean] more in that direction anything that I have ever done or said
Quite Frankly, I think I can see like many people in Europe filled
Now wife and I since the opening of school are
Always careful when we go home, we study the premises when we get in we lock the doors and get the lights on
Any noise or any sound that occurs. We are always concerned at what it is
there have been some nights when we have
felt that it was
The only safe thing for us to do was to stay out of town. We have visited our friends at times
It is just a constant
Thing which I'm sure
It is part of the organization to where myself and my wife now
It's just presses you down every day
lower and lower
And to me it is an amazing thing
There's an American citizen Living Union and States
It has to be subjected to this
While the lowest citizens those who refused to abide or accept the law?
continue to run free
know this is not a true picture of America and
Always not a true picture of the majority of the [people] vanishing kent
But it is a picture [of] myself in
Several other citizens in Clinton who have tried to abide to the law?
The most talked about man in Clinton is John Casper of Washington DC
John Casper still awaiting appeal of a one-year sentence is the self-appointed executive secretary of the seaboard white citizens council
and a protege of Ezra pound
Since his two arrests he is forbidden from interfering in Clinton
But because it is impossible to measure his fully on the community without observing him in action
We followed him to nearby, Kentucky
on
December 12 he was speaking to a white citizens council. Group in a fourth floor law
The argument simply does not hold that the white race being a minority
rather being a majority in the United States
Should turn [over] to a group of people only removed from slavery 80 years and only removed from the jungle by a few hundred years
Turned over to them
the control of our entire civilization
The basis of common law is a custom of the people if the custom of the people in Anderson [County] is to keep the races
Separate then the supreme court law doesn't mean anything. It doesn't
John Casper on the Ku Klux Klan in 11 Years in every Southern State the segregation laws
We are fighting for today were written
Every one up
by the [cue] cross-Claim
which saved the south and
the Men who stood
face-To-face [of] Chickamauga
Braxton Bragg and
General Thomas
If they didn't have a principle to fight and die [for] if they said
well
We'll just let this thing go on
Every single one of us here tonight would be Mulatos and not white
everyone
John Casper on the people of the south
They underestimated the intelligence and the resistance power of the Mountain folk down here in Tennessee and Kentucky
They underestimated that
they thought
Well, maybe they were dealing
Where the Group of Hillbillies rednecks crackers?
but those are the real people the united States make no mistake about and those hillbillies and crackers as
Billy Branham said pure white people living in the face [of] the earth anywhere and the strongest
Among them are men who get on their knees and pray every Sunday and they pray to
They pray hard they believe in that bible, and they believe in Jesus Christ
Mr.. [Caspar] tells of his Clinton Adventure when I was in Charlottesville
I saw a little piece in the Charlottesville paper. Which said [that] integration was a [comer]
in Tennessee for the first time the first school
Clinton High school it happened to be just a day away, [I]
Want to find out how the folks felt about it?
I didn't [think] they were for it, but I didn't tell them anything about that. I just went door-to-door
I showed him a picture of a nigger soldiers kissing some white girl
Probably all seen that picture
Army in the fort MCCLellan, Alabama some say it's Germany doesn't make any difference
They're still niggers in American Army uniforms kissin white girls then make any difference was Germany or Alabama being done wrong
now I
Showed him the picture and niacin [they] knew brought the niggers blowing the school the next day and they said
They knew about it. They heard something about it, or they didn't hear about some of them hadn't even heard about it. [I]
Asked them how they felt about their and they said I'm again
What can we do about?
Nothing, so [I] told them something about picketing
How labor unions operate I?
Told them to be down at the school the following day
Now Monday morning. I would be there with them and we ticket and we discussed this thing with a local official
We'd find out. What if anything could be done about it?
John Casper on politicians what we are trying to do is regain local control of local affairs and
It is local government
Local corruption we must deal with first you can hardly expect to have a choice
between [a] hollow pumpkin in [a] hopeless the [Challah] pumpkin or nepal [who's] in the [white] [house] now and
The man who ran against them in the recent election national election two men both of them
Dedicated to stupidity and treachery both of them
doesn't mean a thing either one of them you compare them to the
Patron Saint of the Republican or democratic [party's] Jefferson or or Lincoln or any of those people why these men are nothing?
Our president today
They're just sworn enemies of the American Republic
sworn enemies of the Constitution
Do everything they can their power to destroy it have consistently for 35 years
Each each and every one of them
John [Kasper] on the Supreme Court the idea is
Clear I think in everybody's mind
That the right aim of law is to prevent coercion either by Force or by fraud and the supreme court decision is exactly
Precisely fraudulent precisely coercive
But the supreme court is in there for life and the whole federal judiciary is in there for life
And there is nothing you can do about impeachment is silly. [I] mean it just it's so hard to accomplish that
Probably easier to assassinate me
[Supreme] [court], we know they're communists. We know that to combine nine men in the supreme court. Don't make one good
Civil Claims judge
But yet on the other hand combined. They make one of the most deadly
Communists Hydra head Monsters we've ever known
But I'm absolutely confident. We are going to destroy that do I
Say integration can be reversed it can be stopped anywhere
Provided an attack is made at every single level
But meetings of the County court are attended that the constant self-same demands are made that people people keep hitting the judge
Who made the [original] ruling that pressure tremendous pressure is brought to bear on that school principal?
On the school board on the local newspaper, or whoever it is it happens to [be] responsible?
There's no sense any longer of Killington senator So-and-so
Or [president] or the president or the supreme court [judge] it got to be a pressure down [here] which is
More or less like a lit stick of dynamite, and you throw it in there laughs let them catch it
And then they can do what they want with it, but let them worry about
at nine [o'clock] on the morning of December 4
1956 was conceivably the darkest hour of the worst day in [Clinton's] history
The reverend Paul Turner a baptist was beaten up after escorting six negro youths to school
There were witnesses it was a it was a horrible thing and I thought they were actually killing him blood was streaming
Down his [face] and even it. Just looked that blood was running out of his eye
[I] asked someone in the group. Just anyone to help him and when there was no response I
Went to him and tried to assist him by pulling some of the men's arms for around his face when all the time the men
In this group who were standing around were screaming kill him and that's exactly what I thought
They were going to do I certainly don't consider that it was
An act of bravery it was just a matter of the right or wrong thing to do and I did what I thought [was] right
and
I'm
Putting on ashamed of the fact that I did it's just that I'm ashamed really for the people of printing that it did happen
In such a nice town first. It's not people live
Reverend Turner is 33 [years] old
I spent all of his life [in] Tennessee for [about] five days these negro students
having of course the legal right to attend Clinton high school had stayed home because of
harassment and hindrance and heckling and threats upon their lives and incidents that actually would make anybody scared I
Chose to take such a stand on this Moral principle
that as long [as] the law is the law as it [is] in our land and
As long as they did personally choose to come to Clinton High school
They're legal right that [they] had a moral right to attend on heckled and unhindered and on arrest
It was [this] that prompted men to accompany them
Though there were quite a few hecklers. We made our way [to] the high school building without any overt incident
when I emerged from the school building about five or ten minutes later the
[hecklers] were still there and they heckled me personally about
[300] yards away from the High school we were far away from
Where the policemen were doing their duty of course in front of the high school?
one of the
citizens [Council] members had stationed himself with about three of the men on the corner as
I made my way to that corner. They jumped me I?
retreated across the Street Bob Street of Clinton
Trying to keep him at arm's length
While the other fellows were trying to surround me and to hold my arms and get me stationary for the beating I
Retreated all the way across the street trying to avoid any incident finally found myself pretty well backed up
against the Bishop building on the other side of the street I knew then that I had [to] do something and
[it] was at that time also that one man successfully held my arms down and
Allowed the number one
Man of their gang to land a pretty good blow upon my nose
it was at that time also that I realized I had to defend myself in some way and [so] I took off after the
Man, who?
had slugged me pinned him against a car and
Immediately about eight to ten people were on [our] backs
after a while when the police arrived
Everybody scattered pretty much. We came up from our position bending over
I took a hold of the two fellows that led the attack one in one hand one in the other and
Shoved each of them into the arms of a policeman and from there they took them on over to the police station I
Retreated into a doctor's office
But everyone did not applaud reverend Turner's act which coincidentally occurred on the same day [that] Clinton was electing a new mayor
James Meredith a grocer running for Mayor with the backing of the white Citizens Council was badly defeated
Claims that the REv Run's action may have swung the election to his opponent
my name's James P murder Farm operator, the City food Market in Clinton, Tennessee
I was in this Mayor's ratio, December the 4th
1956 which I was defeated
Well about the election. I think [there's] [a] lot of misrepresentation
a lot of it start here in this Clinton current news
Which is a local weekly newspaper
here
I've been here a resident of this
[County] around 2000 about in 20 years
[where] he had representatives if I might have been Jesse James or somebody just come in here on a
horse [rode] [into] [town] got old which that was untrue
I've been here on this street for about
20-some years operating a grocery store. They made it out to be segregation against
integration as
For me. I'm right there 95 percent. I'd say the people here in Anderson County I am
against integration of of course we believe in negro
Having equal rights equal
education and equal facilities
but we think he should have them in their own place as for being endorsed by the white Citizen Council as
Everybody knows I came out in this race on mon as my friends came in the store here and in case
To run this mayor's race. I was running a good race and this Mayor's race up
until the morning before the polls open while
this minister
He went up on the hill to buying the niggers down to school minute do you meditate to that?
Why the stuff will I hear started down?
Some war in the [lore] in Town
That was a proximate said by [10] Ms before the polls open
as to whether or not that was political
I don't know mom's done
Was that [nigger's] wasn't supposed to come school at morning?
But I figure I'll come back and either [2] or [4] years from now and win in this Mayor's race
There were other merchants involved and some were losing customers because they stood by the court order
This is our g Krosno Chairman of the school board
I'm sure there's no doubt in your mind mister my official connection with [the] dairy company as president of large premium corporated
We [too] have heaven
threats
for carnival product in a number of instances
We have lost accounts. Which we have served 10 for 15 years
as a result of [my] being a member of this particular school board
But I would like to assure you as a faculty and my fellow members on the board
if becomes necessary
Me to make a decision as to whether I sell a [quota] [meal] or resign from the school board
[I] would like to show you here now that I will [not] [serve] [a] [quarter] [mil] for will remain a member of the school board
Also on December 4th the Principal's wife was knocked down and several white and colored children were beaten
The school board asked for federal protection and at 11:45 closed the high school until order could be restored
Mrs., Eleanor Davis a mother and a teacher
Explains to a pTa group what it was like we were stunned
There were some who were jubilant
sure
they had wanted it to happen and
They rejoice
but now they didn't have to go to school and
They could keep other people from going to school who really wanted an education
But those were few in number
There were other students who were so stunned they didn't know whether to leave or [not] going down the hall I found students crying I
Found seniors who were bitter because they felt that they might not be able to graduate
Course tension had been high and you can imagine the reaction [to] various reaction after the students left the faculty didn't want to leave
Somehow we just couldn't leave
We met together in a faculty room
We felt the seating we felt as if we'd weighed the flag of surrender, and we did not to wave a flag of Surrender
We didn't want to admit that we couldn't control the situation. [it] was not until the
Acquittal of [Kasper] in our local [Criminal] [Court] and the [organisation] of the Youth Council
That we began to have a breakdown within the school
The members [of] the Youth Council were not all students
But among those who were students
We had some habitual troublemakers disciplinary problems students who?
found it difficult to pass and
some of the students who belong to the youth Council
Were so ashamed of the fact that they had to belong that?
[they] refused to wear their badges
They had only joined at the insistence of their parents
They refused to [participate] in any of the trouble [mates] I know
Because I talked with it
There are [a] few students who have been so sensitive to this situation to the things that they've heard on our
scene on the outside that they have drawn within themselves and
They're not the same as they used to be. [they're] afraid to express themselves and
They've lost that happy carefree attitude of you
Of course we hope that time will heal that and they will be
[once] more
They're happy failed
Now I don't think anybody can say
enough
Concerning the courage of the negro students [themselves] who are [willing] [to]?
face persecution in
their hometown to
[get] an education
The majority of students, and I do mean a majority
have undergone this crisis with great courage and
faced it intelligently
Trying to be courteous and helpful
at all times and
I think these students have grown up a little bit as a result
That Sunday with the [school] still closed and the FBI still in town
Reverend Turner faced his all-white congregation for the first time since his controversial act the bible is without
Precedent as a book and I personally have no fear that it will ever be superseded
But many have tried to misuse the bible trying to justify some low standard of conduct
By the very bible that they profess to love and by the book that never
compromises with sin with pride with prejudice or with hate
Billy Graham tells the Following Story
shortly after the Civil [war] in a very fashionable church in Richmond, Virginia
There [interred] a negro man one Sunday morning, when communion was being served
He walked down the aisle and took his place at the altar to partake of the elements of the Lord's supper
There was a rustle of anger that swept through the congregation
sensing this delicate situation a distinguished gentleman stood up and
Walking [down] the aisle. He took his place by his colored brother
Immediately his magnificent example
Swept over the spirits of the rest of the people in that congregation, and they followed him [to] the altar taking their place there, too
This man was none other than Robert ely
My friends we have been too far away from God when mobs are able in our land to flout the law
The tragic result is a Cicero, Illinois or a phoenix City, Alabama
Here in Clinton. We are not especially
Against integration we are not especially
against segregation, but we are positively and
definitely
Against the disintegration of our community and our body politic that we cherish above all things
Realizing that where our energy prevails none of us has anything of any value and none of us has any freedoms
anymore and
Now we realize more clearly than ever before that it is Christ or Chaos
May we pray
Principal Britain had invited the County attorney [Eugene] [Joyce] to tell the student body what the law expected of them I?
Am here this morning in my official capacity as
County attorney to tell you what in the future the board of education and this faculty will expect of you as
Students, it is [not] my intention to tell you what to think
nor it is my nor is it my desire [to] tell you what to believe but
It is my [duty] to tell [you] how to act in the future so long as you are students at Clinton High School
to my knowledge never in the history of
American education
Has it been necessary?
To read an instrument such as this [to] [a] specially called student assembly
I have been asked now to read to you this injunction from the United States
District Court of the Eastern District of Tennessee
Northern Division
And this far is it appearing from Sworn petition?
But even before the school had been reopened that the long arm of the federal law had taken over
U.s. Marshals had moved into Clinton and arrested 16 men and women accused of violating judge Taylor's injunction
Their arraignment took place in nearby Knoxville on December 10 the same day school reopened
here are eight of the defendants on their way to the courthouse [and]
[here] is the voice of the County attorney reading the injunction that on august the 29th
1956 a crowd of people
Agitated by one John casper attacked one of the negro children of the school that casper stated on various occasions
that the court had no authority to issue the aforesaid order of
Desegregation in the Clinton High school and that it should not be obeyed it
Is ordered and decreed by the court that the effort mentioned persons their agents servants?
Representatives attorneys and all other persons who are acting or act in concert with them?
be and they hereby are
enjoined and prohibited from Further hindering
obstructing or in any wise
interfering with the carrying out of the [aforesaid] order of this court or
from thickening Clinton High School either by words Or acts or
otherwise
The young woman under arrest is Mrs.. Ellen nelson daughter of clem Dishman
Reporter morse talked to Dishman at his home on College Hill
This is the phlegm Dishman who's lived in Clinton for 20 years?
has his own garage downtown
Clem what do you think about the situation here in Clinton way? I understand it is a
My daughter and the rest of these folks here
Will sign [up] to be a witness in this?
Little case here the city of priors are fighting inside [the] corporation
They gather them up, and they take them over to Austin they put them in put them in jail over
Even cutting our daughter in there with I think is either six or seven
Criminal women where I look at it just in the bullpen
And I don't can't see nothing far about that you see what I what what needs to be done way. I look at now
These there's only about six or eight of them here. It goes to school. I think they claim these eight. What [cutting] them people just
Go to some other [stew]. [they] got a cutter school yet nozzle, and then Anderson County
Offered [they] the two issues frank Shabazz ranch the gas they even wind up one foot enough to furnish a colored driver
They [ask] for colored driver
We hear they're
Just before the pastor went up on the hill to lead them all to die the bus they didn't notion to going that much notion
To go on well. He goes up and caused all this trouble see the pastor of the first Baptist church
Bald hanger goes up on the hill over here leads the [colored] [all] puts the minuscule goes over town in has his back I
Thank the supreme court when they ruled
that the health segregation ever were I
Think they're trying [to] mist off the legend shortage where look at it now
I don't I don't know too much about over the if it'll work in one place. It'll work in another you're working all
You take Justin and I'm in outfit or whatever you might want to call it
Well over in Russia. They got the same thing over we understand to get the same nine
Lulululu for that kent I don't think that's what I think that's calmness. We're doing [dennis] now
I'll tell you what I think about that's just what I think about see what [I] mean, you know well, what do you think about?
[about] [John] [Kerry], I think John Casper's real man. I
Think I think you kind of got him under a bad deal this year in the base [stepped] myself now
I'm just telling from a personal self, so you're thinking
That's what I'll think about [casper]. They don't think he's firing man, [nowhere]
He just woke us up around here, and then people around here this German twee living under the way. I look at it
But he just won't fess up to the fact that we're just living on anything mark anybody might want to do around here this newspaper
Over here wells out here to inspire on that stand [over]
[I] said he putting that paper what he thought the county needs to know the man runs the paper out here in this town
Thanks very much, Mr.. Dishman appreciate your talking you've
Got a match good
Fishman's daughter is no longer in Clinton High school because her father doesn't want her in a desegregated school
Joanne Allen's father has withdrawn her for a different reason
They're getting out
my name is Herbert Allen, and I've lived in Clinton for
24 Years and
[I] found it to be a nice little town to live in very peaceful very quiet
We never had any trouble in this little town thing like this happens
[sometime] we say overnight, but this thing is to be and
quite natural some
Doesn't think it should be?
but God said he created all [men] equal and all men alive and
so therefore
none of us stands above the other person in yards sight and
We as a negro race we are only in Clinton
Tennessee abiding by the supreme court ruling that we'd [sent] our children to the high school in Anderson County
We haven't broken in law
we had went against the court ruling but we
Leave in now for the Los Angeles, California, not so much [soars] because of this situation, but that I might better myself
And that Joanne might have a little bit more freedom in
her school activities and
in her
career
doing all the
excitement all
[the] things that the people are doing I was able to accomplish something
I made two a's and [a] [b] and the only grade grade it was [a] C
Which isn't very bad, but I wish it had [been] an a or b one um
My teachers were [very] proud [of] me and my parents were too because they thought I did well
even through all the
strain that
We did have to go through because sometimes I couldn't keep my mind on my [lesson] for thinking about the people on the outside
But they were thinking [up]
And we're not leaving here with hatred in our hearts
against anyone
even those who was against - we do not hate those people because we realized that those people just misled and
They was trained and brought up the way that way yes. Why did they were never one able to understand?
Clinton High school resumed four days ago after the scheduled Christmas recess with 655 students enrolled
There were no incident some say that the worst is over
That although there is still little enthusiasm for desegregation
There is now a strong will to comply with the law
There are those in Clinton who say the big change came when the federal marshals and the FBI moved it?
others
among them Editor Horace Wells
Claimant was reverend Turner's beating
Another thing that has come about hey, I think this is largely due [through] the attacked on Paul Turner the other day
was that many of us had stood by
Unwilling to stand up for integration and yet
Also, unwilling to violate the law and when [Paltin] was attacked the the feeling of the community was more less solidified
No, [male] words could have done it it took some kind of action a heroic action
Something are the this being that was administrative alternate to bring us?
To the point where we were willing to stand up and say now we are not going to put up with being pushed around anymore
[we] believe in law and order, [and] that's what we want
that's what we're going to have and
That's the reason that the people were willing to go to Knoxville and and put them out of a federal judge [tale] and say now
We want this order
enforced
The trial of the 16 Clinton Defendants is set for January 28th
There are those who [questioned] the [legality] of the injunction?
including the atTorneys [general] of three Southern States and a few colonists the courts will decide as
for Clinton a joint meeting of the junior and senior Chambers of Commerce
unanimously adopted a resolution
upholding the desegregation law
In the last four months we've [had] a lot [of] controversial
Worldwide, publicity on Clinton most of which has been brought about by [a] very small minority of the local citizens
most of us are peaceful law-abiding home loving people that whore violence and
Mob action
We believe in our government in our laws and the justices handed down by our courts even though [our] government and our laws
And our courts don't always pleased us as individuals
We as Americans and citizens believe first in both in personal freedom
This personal freedom is not the freedom to form mobs and take the law into our own hands
But freedom to think for ourselves
And if an issue doesn't please us to use every legal peaceful means at our command
to change the issue
The Bill of rights is also a bill of obligation I
Read that somewhere the other day, but it's good it fifth
Today, we're not concerned with whether you are for or against segregation
And we're just concerned with whether or not you're for [or] against law and order
That was Clinton and the law an examination after the fact of what happened in Clinton, Tennessee
This was in no sense an effort to examine the whole complex problem of segregation as such
In other communities both the problems and the solutions may not be identical to those that were reached in Clinton, Tennessee
Now for see it now good night, and good luck